ok ok bonjour à tous bienvenue pour
cette conférence organisée par le préfet
les a la faculté d'informatique de le
pfl donc ça fait c'est un grand plaisir
pour moi que de pouvoir accueillir ici
thibault giro vous connaissez peut-être
sous le nom de monsieur fit donc
thibault a eu à sa thèse de le sss
l'école des hautes études en sciences
sociales en philosophie donc c'est un
vrai pied je dis pas comme les
scientifiques y sont pas vraiment pied
du lit et et puis deux puis il a lancé
sa chaîne youtube qui marche vraiment du
tonnerre où il aborde plein de sujets
qui sont fascinants en philosophie
vraiment très intéressant et aujourd'hui
va nous parler de super intelligent
c'est de plus précisément de comment
penser intelligemment une super
intelligence annoncé cette annonce et
surtout pour les gens sur youtube juste
après ça on fera faut pas juste après
sam à 19 heures on fera aussi un épisode
actuellement live donc penser aussi à
aller voir ça après cette conférence
parole merci les polarisations ça fait
très plaisir et
merci aux organisateurs le pfl merci à
je ne sais qui a fait ce visuel qui est
très jolie je pense c'est ma plus belle
slide parce qu'après c'est moi qui fait
le reste et je me rends compte en
regardant cette slide que la notion que
super intelligence est le titre de cette
conférence que de créer d un peu de
fausses attentes donc pour commencer je
voulais juste préciser un point c'est
que je vais parler de super intelligence
mais je vais pas parler seulement
d'intelligence artificielle en fait
pendant une peu près une moitié je vais
parler de d'intelligence en général et
de dessus de super intelligent que de
façon assez générale et voilà quelle
qu'elle soit artificielle ou non et même
je veux soutenir que dans une certaine
mesure la super intelligent salle est
déjà là et elle est pas spécialement
artificiel voilà je reviendrai là dessus
donc
voilà si je veux pas parler trop
d'intelligence artificielle c'est parce
que j'ai senti moi lorsqu'on parle de
super intelligent c'est qu'on lit ça à
l'intelligence artificielle assez vite
on se retrouve à parler de trucs qui
semble un petit peu un petit peu fou et
catastrophistes et j'ai pas envie de
ressembler à quelqu'un de fouet
catastrophe ici pour des raisons
évidentes parce que c'est pas flatteur
et j'ai quand même en parler je ne vous
inquiétez pas abandonner y aura des
machines et tout ça et des scénarios
apocalyptiques mais pas tout de suite on
va essayer d'y aller doucement
voilà c'est un sujet assez périlleux la
super intelligent sur cette raison là
voilà on en reparlera quand j'entendrai
la voilà cette dimension un petit peu
folle de la super intelligent je vais
commencer par quelque chose de tout à
fait léger un petit peu annexes voilà c
c slide surprenant donc que fait
christophe lambert et gary oldman sur ma
première cela il faudrait se demander
je voulais aborder la question qui
m'intéresse ou en anglais un petit peu
détournée à travers des problématiques
qui se posent pour les écrivains
d'oeuvres de fiction
alors si vous aussi vous avez reconnu
d'où sortent ces deux images vous voyez
peut-être vous je vous rends venir
mettre la première image là christophe
lambert c'est christophe lambert dans le
rôle de connor il s'appelle dans
highlander et à des images c'est une
guerrière de même dans le rôle de
dracula de coppola
adapté de bram stocker et voilà ces deux
personnages ils ont quelque chose dans
l'eau comme un bien d'autres voilà dans
la littérature c'est très très fréquents
si vous connaissez vous voyez sans doute
toujours venir c'est que ils sont ils
sont immortels et surtout en fait là en
l'occurrence lorsqu'on les voiles à
cette époque là ils ont vécu quelque
chose comme cinq siècles ou plus je sais
plus exactement en tout cas voilà ils
ont vécu longtemps une vraiment très
longtemps bien que longtemps que
n'importe quel être humain a jamais vécu
voilà donc les gens qui ont vécu
peut-être son temps et encore avec un
cerveau qui tend à se dégrader
finalement assez vite il aurait vécu
quelque chose comme cinq siècles avec un
cerveau qui de deux jeunes de 20 ans si
vous voulez et la question qui se pose
pour un écrivain qui voudrait écrire des
personnages qui ont vécu cinq siècles et
des faire agir les faire parler et
défaire voilà avoir un comportement
[Musique]
et bien c'est de savoir question qu'est
ce qui passerait dans la tête de
quelqu'un qui a vécu aussi longtemps et
c'est une question en fait
extraordinairement difficile quelque
part c'est une question si on la prend
au sérieux
essayer vraiment d'imaginer qu'est ce
qui se passe dans la tête comme on
parlerait comment penserait comment
quelqu'un qui a vécu cinq siècles
analysera la situation et réagir et
c'est extraordinairement difficile une
autre façon d'essayer de se rendre
compte à quel point c'est difficile sous
pour ce genre d'exercice à elle je vais
souvent faire ça en fait qu'en france à
la super intelligent c'est une des
meilleures façons d'apprendre et le truc
c'est de ces de renverser la perspective
de dire j'essayais d'imaginer situation
symétrique dans cette situation pour
pour parler de ce problème là ça serait
imaginé une situation où un enfant de 7
8 ans est serré d'écrire une histoire
pour notre personnage qui aurait vécu
plusieurs décennies qui aurait vécu 50
60 ans c'est peut-être pas fou oui avec
ceci de particulier que ce sera un
enfant de 7 8 ans qui n'auraient jamais
qui vivraient dans une communauté
d'enfants au fait qu'il n'aurait jamais
rencontré l'adulte qui y ont vécu une
autre juste entre enfance j'ai imaginé
ce serait une sorte de tribune dans food
voilà d'enfants qui auraient le même
genre de cerveaux que nous mais
simplement physiologiquement sera un peu
différent ça se développerait beaucoup
plus vite et mon gré vers l'âge de 10-11
ans maximum vous imaginez un enfant à 7
8 ans qui serait d'imaginer
ce que serait la société de dom qui
vivrait plusieurs décennies ça va
paraître un peu fou parce qu'on vit pas
plusieurs décennies pour on sent bien
que mal pris c'est de raconter une
histoire autour de tout ça mais quelque
part ce sera un peu à côté de la plaque
ce qui racontera à propos des êtres
humains on sent bien déjà qu'il écrirait
pas très bien voilà
et que voit ce qu'il écrivait surtout au
sujet de dents d'adulte de 50 60 ans ce
sera absolument ridicule ce serait un
adulte 2,50 qu'il irait ça non c'est pas
comme ça qu'on est en fait qu on est à
l'âge adulte
et finalement quand bram ce qu'a essayé
d'écrire dracula il est dans la même
situation il essaye d'écrire les pensées
et le comportement d'un de quête d'un
être qui aurait vécu comme ça qu'ils
avaient traversé plusieurs siècles et
quand on lit quand lebron stocker et de
façon générale quand lille dans la
science fiction dans un fantastique des
personnages pour ce genre de
caractéristiques là et c'est assez
fréquent c'est toujours un peu raté
c'est toujours un peu mauvais et c'est
normal parce qu'en fait ça peut pas être
beau de tout simplement parce que pour
savoir exactement qu'est ce qui se
passera dans la tête de quelqu'un qui
aurait vécu cinq siècles
bah il faudrait il faudrait être faudra
avoir vécu cinq siècles au moins ou
connaître des gens qui auraient vécu
cinq siècles et surtout on n'en sait
rien des gens qui ont vécu 5,6 ça
n'existe pas
et en attendant que ça existe c'est très
très très c'est extrêmement difficile
d'imaginer vraiment qu'est ce qu'on peut
penser en ayant vécu cinq siècles
et voilà c'est toujours un peu ratée
quand les personnages je suis pas en
train de dire que dans ce cas la mondeo
terre gelée sur dix c'est inévitable ça
fait partie de d'une limitation je
résume ça en disant par cette formule en
disant que personnage de fiction n'ai
jamais beaucoup plus intelligent que son
auteur quelque part c'est une vie dans
un personnage de fiction ne peut pas
être beaucoup plus intelligent que son
auteur parce que pour écrire vraiment un
personnage de fiction extraordinairement
intelligent ma fenêtre
l'auteur extraordinairement intelligent
donc voilà les et très bon auteur il va
faire des personnages de fiction très
intelligent parce qu'ils sont très
intelligents les auteurs d'une
intelligente ce médiocre font rares des
personnages même qu'elle va faire des
grands méchants qui sont très
intelligents ils sont en fait un pub est
leur grand méchant parce que voilà
l'intelligence en général d'un
personnage ressemble à l'intelligence de
son auteur on peut éventuellement faire
un peu mieux un peu moins mais pas
beaucoup plus et alors ça paraît être un
long détour mais je vais parler beaucoup
de choses car ce gars là qui font écho à
ça c'est à dire comment réussir à
décrire analyser une intelligence qui
serait très supérieure à la nôtre
ça semble poser un problème radical qui
est que on essaye de le faire avec notre
intelligence notre intelligence limite
fondamentalement notre capacité à
décrire des intelligences on peut on
peut penser d intelligence très
supérieurs mais ce sera ce jour de très
loin de façon très très abstrait très
flou
là j'ai pris ces exemples-là qui sont
pourtant pas si a priori pas si
difficile en fait parce que c'est ça
reste l'intelligence humaine
c'est juste d'intelligence humaine mais
qui aurait lu beaucoup plus d'expérience
qui serait assez longtemps et déjà on
sent bien que ça poserait un problème
que ce serait bon que ça serait très
difficile d'arriver à une une
description qui serait vraiment crédible
qui serait vraiment pertinente si si les
prix des exemples d'intelligence machine
qui qui serait forcément très supérieure
à la nôtre évidemment dans la science
fiction c'est toujours totalement
ridicule ce genre de choses pour des
raisons pour les mêmes raisons mais
amplifié si vous voulez bon voila
c'était un petit détour par la fiction
que se trouve toujours amusant si vous
aimez la science fiction vous ai repensé
ce principe là qui me paraît
généralement vrai qu'un personnage de
fiction que jamais être plus un sujet de
son auteur puis on sort servira parce
que dans la super intelligent s'il ya
beaucoup d'éléments de fiction justement
qui sont un peu inséparable de la
réflexion c'est vrai c'est par
intelligence justement maintenant allez
passons aux choses sérieuses on a parlé
un petit peu de de l'intelligence on
essaie préciser un peu le sens de cette
de cette notion alors une première ce
succès conscient du fait que c'est
extrêmement difficile à définir
je vais pas essayer de donner vraiment
une définition avec laquelle on sera
d'accord c'est pas possible
mais même si ces traductions à définir
on en a une compréhension intuitive déjà
dire c'est peut-être une telle vente
laquelle c'est si difficile à définir
c'est qu'on en a une compréhension
intuitive et donc à chaque fois qu'on a
une définition bien il peut toujours se
heurter à cette compréhension du typhon
dans la si vous voulez c'est comme si
c'est comme si on faisait face à un
nuage dont les bords sont pas très
nettes et définir quelque chose comme
l'intelligence se seraient tracées une
limite de ce nuage est forcément en plus
trace une limite qui serait faite en
quelques points assez simple et
forcément le nuage et à débord un peu
floue et qu'on essaie de tracer ses
limites sur l'impression que c'est pas
tout à fait satisfaisant c'est pas
toujours bien où ça passe et puis
surtout si vous demandez à deux
personnes différentes
elle trace ont pas la même forme au même
nuage pourtant on voit bien le même
nuage mais voilà le l'ambiguïté des
bords des bords de l'intuition fait que
tout le monde ne sera sera pas la même
limite mais ça veut pas dire que l'on
peut pas parler d'intelligence parce que
tout de même il ya des des traits
communs sur lesquels on peut s'accorder
et quand même des points qui font du
vrai consensus et donc j'essaie de
maquiller avant tout sur ces points là
donc je ne vais pas arriver une
définition d'intelligence mais disons
aux moi j'essaie de mettre en avant des
points consensuels et qui sont
importants pour qu'on réfléchisse à ce
sujet là donc quelques points
consensuels le commerçant qu'élever
l'appuyer c'est cette idée que j'ai
vraiment abordés intelligence souvenant
de la résolution de problèmes ou le fait
de se fixer un objectif est d'arriver à
atteindre cet objectif
voilà je suis pas en train de dire ça
serait dû à sa medi scellier à centre
être intransigeant c'est vous pouvez
dire c'est une capacité en tout cas
c'est lié à la capacité à atteindre
divers objectifs à résoudre divers
problèmes à accomplir diverses tâches et
c'est important cette idée de diversité
là dedans ça c'est pas une minute à
particulier mais c'est une diversité des
tâches diverses étaient objectifs et
s'amène au deuxième point qui est que
l'intelligence est susceptible de degré
multiples et ça paraît assez évident
mais c'est important quand ça le sujet
qui l'a super intelligent puisque
justement c'est une incidence degré très
supérieurs et mais ces petits degrés
multiples mais pas seulement sur un seul
axe on a bien l'idée justement parce que
ça c'est lié à une capacité à atteindre
divers objectifs à résoudre divers
problèmes que ça ne s'est pas tout à
fait pertinent l'évaluer seulement sur
un seul axe on a bien sentiment que ça
serait susceptible de divers degrés mais
aussi sur divers axes et pour bien
souligner cet aspect là c'est important
de distinguer l'intelligence d'une
notion qui serait voisine qui serait une
expertise
voilà l'expertisé qui notions voisines
mais vraiment importante à distinguer
elle a ceci de particulier qu'elle sur
breistroff à un domaine bien précis
l'escale intelligente on aurait cette
idée que c'est plus générale expertise
aussi la seule susceptible de degrés
mais pour le coup ce serait plus
pertinent de penser que les expertises
elles s'évaluent sur un seul axe
si vous prenez l expertise pour jouer
aux échecs
ce serait un sens de classe est
effectivement tous les joueurs d'échecs
du plus mauvais au meilleur voilà ça
fait plus de sens du coup eu une idée
pour établir le lien entre intelligence
expertises ont semblé qu'il ya un lien
entre les deux c'est à dire que si je
développe mon expertise dans plein de
domaines fut plus d'evra cij acquiert
une expertise dans le domaine peut dire
je deviens plus intelligent une façon
sont bien qu'ils auraient un lien entre
entre les deux on pourrait se dire dans
un premier temps que ce serait quelque
chose comme une sorte de méga expertise
du refuge avoir des expertises dans
plein de domaines différents extrêmement
différents
l'intelligence ce serait en tout cas ce
serait liée à l'ensemble
artiste dans un grand nombre de domaines
et pourquoi pas mais il y aurait un
deuxième élément qui me paraîtrait en
fait plus important que celui ci qui
serait là l'idée d'une capacité à
acquérir de la clé rapidement de l
expertise dans un grand nombre de
domaines
ces deux éléments là en tout cas j'ai
dis pas que ça ferait une définition
d'une intrusion sur lequel tout le monde
soit prêt à s'accorder parce qu'encore
une fois je pense pas que l'on puisse y
arriver mais en tout cas je pense c'est
des points qui je l'espère vous
reconnaîtrez comme étant assez
consensuel et bien alors ensuite juste à
passer la prochaine saipa ce que je la
trouve assez moche j'ai fait ce que j'ai
pu
c'est vu les avoirs des cendres de
représentation visuelle c'est pour
introduire la super intelligent de faire
très simple visuel
je vais essayer de représenter de façon
visuelle l'intelligence humaine et
différentes formes d'intelligence et
donc voilà ce que ça donnait alors je
sais pas ce que vous pouvez lire en fête
c'est un peu petit c'est presque une
note pour moi même donc c'est quoi
l'idée de lier ces pour le premier
l'intelligence humaine
en fait imaginer que chaque direction du
plan par rapport au point central
correspond à une certaines tâches que
l'être humain est capable de réaliser et
disons que l'ensemble des directions des
par rapport à ce point ce point la forêt
ont fait le tour de toutes les tâches
que l'être humain ne pas briser disons
que des objectifs qu'un être humain
capable de réaliser
donc c'est par exemple on pourrait dire
que l' axe horizontal donc voilà on dans
ce sens là ça serait la tâche qui serait
joué aux échecs par exemple et admettons
que la sept longueurs là donc c'est pour
ça que ça forme un cercle dont on va
dire c'est une sorte d'étalon donc sept
longueurs lacan correspond à
l'efficacité dans la réalisation de
cette tâche ça correspond à l'efficacité
typiquement humaine dans la réalisation
de cette tâche-là donc voila sinon ça
serait une façon de leur présenter
l'intelligence humaine des autres la
montage ce serait une sorte d'étalon et
à partir de ça vous pouvez y réfléchir à
comment est-ce qu'on vous représenterez
d'autres formes d'intelligence que
l'intelligence humaine et par exemple en
dessous là j'ai présenté ce qui serait
une super expertise serait par exemple
quelque chose comme le logiciel stop
fish qui est capable de jouer aux échecs
très très très bien donc l'idée c'est
que lui bah voilà dans ce sens la halle
ce très beau couple on peut augmenter
l'idée que c'est beaucoup plus efficace
dans la réalisation de cette tâche là en
particulier
par contre il ya et il n'y a rien dans
toutes les autres directions n'y a rien
du tout parce qu'en fait stockfisch il
est très très bon faut jouer aux échecs
mais il est un peu monomaniaque ne sais
faire que ça
alors peut-être moi je ne suis pas mis
d'échelle attendues
c'est vraiment juste pour avoir des
stades inspiration visuelle de juste une
intuition visuel derrière tout ça qui
m'intéressait sans doute faudrait faire
quelque chose de beaucoup plus long on
n'a qu'à dire c'est logarithmique donc
et on peut réfléchir donc ça commence
quand représenterait d'autres
d'autres formes de l'intelligence
d'autres notre système par exemple alpha
0 qui est qu' un peu plus doué pour
apprendre différents jeux on sent bien
que devrait être un peu plus
voilà ça devrait être un peu plus large
que la tête ce simple trek qui pourrait
représenter stockfisch mais ça serait
quelque chose comme ça comme un micro
arc de cercle
vraiment c'est ok il a un tout vous est
effectivement il a pu apprendre à jouer
au chaud bio bobo aux échecs mais bon ça
reste quand même relativement accès jeu
de plateau dans tous les cas
effectivement ça dépasse les capacités
humaines
on pourra se poser la question de savoir
promotion reprend très intelligent tu
seras d'un singe par exemple alors je
dis pas très précisément ce soir y'a
rien de précis non c'est toute la maison
intuitivement on a l'impression que ce
serait quelque chose comme un cercle
plus petits en tout cas ou en tout cas
une forme plus petit bon l'air serait
plus petit que que celle ci et vous
voilà ça sert progression de visuel
permet de facilement d'essayer
d'imaginer ce que serait une super
intelligence du coup ce serait super
intelligent de ce serait finalement
avant une sorte quelque chose qui aurait
une super expertise donc long que ça
mais pas dans une seule direction
mais dans toutes les directions de ça de
vrai quelque chose comme ça j'ai changé
d'échelle au passage ce sens a pas assez
impressionnant mais
oui je sais ça de pouvoir l'idée
l'intelligence humaine c'est la super
intelligent ça serait ce grand cerf
quelque chose qui bon si on dessine et
son art de l'intelligence en suivant un
peu laisse le même métal ont bien il
faudrait l'art présenté comme ça ça ça
l'idée alors ça ça correspond
effectivement à ce que dit nick bostrom
dans super intelligence et voilà une
super intelligent c'est n'importe quel
intellect qui excèdent de très loin les
performances sportives de des humains
est dedans virtuellement tous les
domaines donc notez que ce qui est
intéressant avec cette façon-là de
présenter sa super intelligent c'est
quelque part c'est pas vraiment
référence directement à l'intelligence
en fait dire dans cette définition la
mine ostrom non plus et c'est pas mal
parce que vraiment l'intelligence est
une notion qui est un peu trop flou donc
là parce que finalement la ddt sur mon
schéma jeu les questions que de tâches
voilà chaque direction correspond à une
taffe intuitivement et juste ensuite la
longueur correspond à l'efficacité voilà
j'ai pas le temps d'évaluation de la
performance dans cette tâche là et c'est
tout j'ai su tout ce que je suis en
train de dire ça serait d'imaginer
quelque chose qu'ici on voit là c'est
d'évaluer ses performances dans
l'ensemble des tâches que l'être humain
est capable de réaliser
eh bien ça devrait quelque chose dans ce
goût là donc c'est vrai que ce genre de
représentation est bien meilleure qu'une
représentation comme on fait souvent
faim comme on voit parfois et c'est
parfois comme un comme ça que c'est un
peu caricaturée la sauce super
intelligent c'est à dire ben on va
organiser un axe sur lequel j'aurai
toutes les intelligences mesurer le
degré zéro et puis après il y aurait la
fourmi après je peux y aura
l'intelligence de la belette fut un
séjour du chef des urgences de l'homme
et puis bien plus loin et réinvention de
la super intelligence voilà une
autorisation une dimension acquis pour
les raisons que j'ai expliqué
précédemment me semble
ça me semble préférable effectivement
une mention s'étendre là après il ya
quelque chose qui me viennent en fait
dans cette représentation de la super
intelligent aussi et c'est intéressant
de réfléchir à ce qui me gêne même nom
en fait ce genre de ce genre de façon de
considérer la super intelligence comme
étant en gros imaginez une intelligence
qui choque parce que l'être humain c'est
l'intelligence le fera mieux ça focalise
même énormément l'attention sur les
tâches dans lesquels l'être humain est
capable de faire quelque chose tout
simplement voilà on est capable
d'évaluer la performance humaine et
c'est en comparaison de cette
performance humaine qu'on va dire que
que c'est une super intelligent ce parce
que ça dépasse la performance humaine
dans tout l'est il ya des tas de
domaines dans lesquels ça le absence
parler de performance humaine
en fait vous bien comprendre que là
quand je parle de ce petit certes la
direction qui seront pas par rapport à
ce point là je parle de tâches qu'un
être humain est capable d'effectuer donc
mais un être humain à être humain seul
et je sais pas si sûr si on pourrait
mettre quelque part quelque chose comme
envoyer quelqu'un sur la lune dans cette
dans cette représentation là si vous y
réfléchissez bien voilà escompté à
évaluer la performance de quelqu'un là
ils sont ici évaluer l'état commence des
individus dans la tâche joue aux échecs
en a qui sont bons qu'ils sont mauvais
la tâche envoyer quelqu'un sur la lune
qui est bon dans cette tâche là qui est
mauvais est ce qu'il ya vraiment des
différences de degré on a bien senti mon
nom un certain sens on est tous aussi
nul dans cette tâche là neil armstrong
compris ni lens on n'est pas meilleur
qu'un autre fois et je sais pas et l
ingénieur qui travaille qui travaillent
la nasa n'est pas meilleur qu'un autre
dans cette tâche là en réalité tout le
monde est aussi nul que voilà tout le
monde et nul à cette tâche là donc
quelque part serait pas trop de sens de
la représenter
sur ce voilà on imagine plutôt des
tâches de type j'ai pas joué aux échecs
jouer au gault distinguer les chats des
chiens marché 40 kilomètres des trucs
non comme un être humain vraiment
capable de faire plus ou moins bien mais
aller sur la lune ça fait partie des
tâches qu'un être humain est capable
d'accomplir et du coup mais ça fait
partie des tâches que un être humain
capable d'envisager de concevoir un peu
c'est un objectif que l'être humain peut
pour se voir d'ailleurs peut-être depuis
très longtemps
c'est un chasseur cueilleur aussi on
croise un assassin recueillir 200
millions pour il expliqué tiens tu sais
dans 100 milles en bas il y aura des
gens qui marchent pas sur la lune et ça
aura un sens pour lui qu il pourra quand
même comprendre ça et je sois
intéressant de visuellement de montrer
que une super intelligent ce pourrait
aussi donc dépasser les 3 1 face à une
façon de dire dépassé être capable de
réaliser des tâches avec l être humain
il est juste capable de la concevoir la
tâche mais pas du tout d'être performant
en aucun sens que ce soit dans la
réalisation de cette tâche là donc du
coup ça serait quelque chose comme dijon
comme il ya tellement de place dans mon
cercle une idée ce serait de leur côté
du court instant une dimension pourrait
dire voilà maintenant dans cette
présentation là imaginer que chaque
direction de l'espace correspond à un
objectif que l'être humain peut exprimer
peut concevoir et pas nécessairement
réalisé en fait dans la plupart des cas
et qu'il ne peut pas réaliser et
juste dans ce plan là là il y aurait les
tâches que l'être humain est capable de
concevoir et de réaliser
et voilà donc une super intelligence
pourrait potentiellement être voilà
quelque chose dans ce goût là c'est
qu'ils dépassent l'être humain pas
seulement là où là où l'être humain et
évaluable pour ainsi dire mais dans des
tas d'autres tâches
on pourrait même envisager une
intelligente une super des gens ce qui
en fait ne dépasserait pas l'être humain
là où l'être humain et évaluable mais le
dépasserait donc voilà quelque chose qui
serait comme cylindrique si vous voulez
ça serait quand même peut-être reçu par
des gens parce que vous on y reviendra
sur cette idée une superstition
cylindrique si vous dire en tout cas par
rapport à cette augmentation la et
dernier point encore si vous parliez un
chasseur cueilleur d'il ya cent mille
ans effectivement pour être très
impressionné du fait que vos tout cas
étonné de cette idée que l'objectif
aller sur la lune
et puis être réalisé sans doute ce
serait pas une des très précise de la
difficulté de la tâche mais il faudrait
pour être représenté alors si vous le
dit on à détecter des ondes
gravitationnelles
l'objectif même que qu'on est en train
de lui qu'il faudrait c'est admirable
mais ça lui dirai rien points se dire et
j'ai envie de rajouter du coup quelque
chose qui n'est pas visualisables mais
qui serait l'ensemble des objectifs dans
son ensemble des tâches l'ensemble des
problèmes quand on n'est juste pas
capable d'envisager de concevoir tout
simplement il y en aurait probablement
beaucoup je peux pas vous donner
d'exemple parce que vous donnez des
exemples a posteriori c'est typiquement
je peux vous dire pour un chasseur
cueilleur le problème consiste à essayer
de détecter une gravitationnelle est pas
concevable
le problème consiste à essayer d'aller
sur la lune les conçois mais des effets
secondaires et à sion il est par contre
cela et pourtant voilà ça pourrait être
aussi un des espaces dans lequel on est
super intelligent ce pourrait être plus
intelligents que nous il vous faudrait
leur côté dans un espace de dimension
supplémentaire
je suis pas vous le montrer et forcément
c'est un petit peu ça l'idée ce serait
deux vous dire voilà ça ce serait la
partie visible super intelligent ce
qu'il faudrait
imaginez qu'ils auraient peut-être aussi
d'aider les dimensions cachées c'est
très abstrait tout ça parce que je parle
pas encore de super intelligent façon
voilà de façon précise alors justement
je vais essayer de mettre un petit peu
de concret là dedans et on va revenir
cet exemple de de la luxure satwa
intéressant et peut-être vous allez
petit quai quand j'ai dit voilà alliés
sur la lune c'est pas une tâche dans
laquelle l'être humain est performant qu
on pouvait se dire on a quand même
réussi à le faire donc c'est quelque
part ça doit être apportée
l'intelligence humaine
c'est une bonne objections j'étais au
courant
voilà je précise donc face à cette
question là vous voyez bien qu'en fait
il ya une ambiguïté et l'ambiguïté elle
porte sur deux façons de comprendre ce
que veut dire apporter de l'intelligence
humaine
vous pouvez dire il ya des objectifs qui
sont quelques uns à être humain peut
réaliser seule une façon un peu étroit
de comprendre ce qui est à portée de
l'intelligence humaine ce serait ça je
pense pas c'est la façon un peu stricte
dû comprendre
et puis il ya les objectifs qu'un peut
accomplir dans un réseau de coopération
très très large extrêmement complexe
voilà typiquement aller sur la lune
c'est quelque chose que les codes qui
captent qui s'est produit et
mais c'est un immense réseau de
coopération qui a amené ça c'est pas il
ya un être humain qui était vraiment
très beau dans la tâche a les dents sur
la lune et qui a réussi à le faire c'est
pas c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
et c'est quelque chose de très
intéressant ça parce que du coup on a
envie de dire bon si c'est pas
l'intelligence humaine qui
l'intelligence humaine au premier sens
strict qui réalise des choses comme
aller sur la lune qu'ils aient
l'intelligence qui réalise à comment est
ce qu'on pourrait appeler ces voix là
c'est le système qui permet sac
finalement alors j'aurai envie d'appeler
l'on pourrait appeler ça une
intelligence collective souvent seul nom
qu'on donne moi j'aime bien donner
simplement le nom de l'intelligence
sociale au centre aqua alors on la sent
très très large et pourquoi là il ya dan
smith tout à coup qui apparaît parce
qu'en fait ce genre de problème j'ai
pris des exemples plus grande île au
corps avec aller sur la lune et c'est
grandiose mais en fait quelque chose
aussi simple que produire une veste de
laine ou fabriquer un crayon c'est
sarcelles la même complexité
en réalité c'est à dire que c'est un
objectif qui de la même façon ne peut
pas être réalisée qui n'est pas apporter
de l'intelligence humaine fabriquer une
veste de laine fabrique un crayon c'est
pas apporter de l'intelligence humaine
alors c'est ce que défend d adam smith
on n'a pas ça jeu que j'aime beaucoup de
la fin de la de la richesse du premier
chapitre de la récrimination et j'ai
fait une vidéo dessus sur ça je jouais
la vignette je pense qu'elle est pas mal
cette vidéo est on pensait bien c'est
aussi le thème sous jacent de ce petit
essai de
c'est une espèce de fiction de leonardo
reid qui raconte voilà l'histoire d'un
crayon à la première personne s'est
rendue aux genres d'idées ça peut
paraître très paradoxal c'est pourquoi
est ce que ce serait pas apporter de
l'intelligence humaine au même titre que
voilà aller sur la lune aller sur la
lune vous vois bien pourquoi oui
effectivement c'est compliqué mais quand
même faire une baisse de l'eire n'en
veut dire c'est pas si compliqué si
c'est extraordinairement compliquée
alors on demande les quais l'argument de
deux dames smith c'est de dire bon bah
bah si je me demande combien ci doit
travailler pour fabriquer une baisse de
l'aide vous allez on n'a pas une idée
très précise de la façon dont on
fabrique et des valses de vienne au 18e
siècle
mais onze ils vont mal va avoir un
berger qui fabrique qui qui élèvent des
moutons ils t'ont allen après il fixe à
quelqu'un qui va filer un filet puis il
va filer ça à quelqu'un qui va fabriquer
du tilloy la baisse de l'aisne et puis
voilà donc j'ai pas une dizaine de
personnes a tout cassé alors l'objection
cessé de souligner le fait que voilà à
chaque étape de ce 2 7 de cette
fabrication par exemple on a besoin
d'outils de leurs actes et par exemple
le le berger pour s'arrêter juste la
première étape ok il tond la laine lors
ils t'ont pas à l'aise on préfère
d'ailleurs une objection encore avant
dit il à des moutons les moutons ça sera
nulle part longtemps ces espèces
domestiques et mine de rien ça suppose
de travail de beaucoup de gens en
espèces domestiques est sympa mais
disons voir c'était pas l'argument de la
suisse mais huit son arrogance et aurait
plutôt autour du 6 au monde peut le
faire avec n'importe quoi donc il dit il
faut des ciseaux pour couper la laine
voilà si vous n'avez pas de ciseaux vous
pouvez pas
vous êtes est élevé les moutons mais
vous devez pas couper la laine pour
faire la veste de laine d'où sortent et
s'est du coup en fait dans la dans le
processus qui permet d'arriver une veste
de laine on a besoin aussi d'un
processus qui a abouti à la création
d'au moins une paire de ciseaux pour le
berger calif il faut carrément donné le
berger il est ses ciseaux il n'ya pas
les faire lui-même et du coup on peut
rajouter ça dans la liste des gens qui
sont nécessaires pour la faut qu'on
arrive à une baisse de l'aisne on va
mettre la liste des gens qui sont
nécessaires pour obtenir le ciseau et
vous voyez bien que faire des ciseaux
c'est extrêmement compliqué parce qu'il
faut il faut du fer
pour avoir dû faire il faut une mine
pour qu'une mine de fer pour vous pour
avoir une ligne de faire il faut
beaucoup de travail il faut du bois
notamment pour avoir du bois il faut une
scie et voilà il faut il faut toute une
organisation sociale en fait pour
arriver à produire une veste de laine et
au même dit qu'il faut toute une
organisation sociale pour réussir à
aller sur la lune alors c'est plus
évident pour le cas de la lune dépourvu
même pour des choses aussi simples que
un crayon à papier ou une veste de laine
en réalité c'est pas le fruit du travail
de quelques personnes ce n'est pas le
fruit du travail d'une seule personne
non plus et c'est totalement hors de
portée de la 2de de réalisation pour une
seule personne
c'est vraiment le fruit du réseau de
coopération inances extraordinairement
complexe est en fait très difficile à
comprendre
on peut pas être décrite de bout en bout
on peut on décrire des fragments on peut
décrire de loi et vous voir une sorte de
voile des schémas mais dans le détail
vraiment comprendre le processus qui
aboutit à fabriquer une veste de laine à
fabriquer un crayon ou à aller sur la
lune c'est hors de portée de
l'intelligence humaine réellement c'est
pas absurde du coup de dire ça qu'on
vous comprenez vous quand vous voyez
vraiment tout ce qu'il ya derrière on
est et on peut avoir l'impression que ce
serait à porter dans une aussi même
d'aller sur la lune parce que vous dites
mais si je comprends ce qui s'est passé
à la nasa et c'est en fait non c'est pas
juste ça va ça c'est juste le la toute
fin du quelque chose qui en fait a duré
plusieurs millénaires le processus qui
est si vous partez de chasseurs
cueilleurs encore une fois vouloir
expliquer après vous avoir dit à e on a
été sur la lune dans 5 milliards pour
vous avez fait en fait vous fais part
est bon parce que concrètement il faut
il faut pas loin de ça pour réussir à
répondre à cette question
c'est assez frappant et ça donne envie
de considérer l'intelligence sociale
comme déjà une forme de super
intelligent c'est une bonne façon de
voir pourquoi l'intelligence sociale est
une super intelligents ces deux j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure de l'intelligence
d'un chat posée par l'intelligence d'un
numéro commence pour représenterez
l'intelligence humaine par action sans
s'imposer surtout si vous
retenez vraiment que par intelligence
humaine je parle vraiment de ce que les
tâches précises concrètes que quand un
être humain capable de réaliser par
rapport disons aux tâches car la
chanteuse est capable de réaliser bon
clairement ça serait plus petit mais ne
se serait pas radicalement flux petit
j'ai envie de dire la différence entre
la représentation qu'on aurait eu
l'intelligence à poser celle d'être
humain maintenant si vous prenez la
différence entre cette intelligence
collective humaine aujourd'hui
particulier et et l'intelligence
collective d'un groupe de chimpanzés
la différence elle et elle est radicale
c'est là où la différence elle est
vraiment radical bien plus que sur les
différences individuelles finalement
donc voilà pourquoi et puis il ya aussi
ce côté ci vous racontiez un chasseur
cueilleur dire sans milan
aujourd'hui parce que c'est ce que
permet aujourd'hui notre intelligence
sociale ça paraîtrait aussi magique
aussi absurde si aussi fous qu'eux que
les scénarios complètement fou que
raconte à l'aller l'énigme australe etc
à propos de la super intelligent sait
pas clairement il y aura un effet de 1
et fait d'eux des mesures par rapport à
par rapport à ce qui ce qui lui semble
possible qui est du même ordre
et alors évidemment on n'a pas ce
sentiment là d'étrangeté face à la super
intelligence sociale
je pense ça tient à deux raisons qui est
que l'objectif final voilà comme quand
j'achète un crayonné part j'utilise
cette intelligence sociale cette super
intelligence sociale mais c'est pour un
objectif final qui est tout à fait clair
pour moi qui ne connais pas n'est pas
bizarre derrière l'étrange je le
comprends parfaitement
deuxième point aussi et qu'il ya c'est
important surtout quand on va parler
d'intelligence artificielle parce que ça
va être un poids sur lequel ça diffère
c'est que dans le processus qui amène à
la fabrication de ce crayon ou d'aller
sur la lune etc
il n'y a finalement que les objectifs
intermédiaires qui se sont effectivement
elle apporter de l'intelligence humaine
parce que c'est réalisé par des êtres
humains
on va peut-être un peu moins
dernièrement mais de façon générale ça
reste des choses qui sont très
facilement compréhensible dans le détail
pour des êtres humains
il n'y a pas de l'obscurité à ce niveau
là jeanne l'obscurité elle n'est plus
tôt de la complexité de cet ensemble
d'interactions cet ensemble
d'interactions il est
il est impossible à décrire complètement
cet exemple du crayon et à ses célèbres
une tannerie mal utilisé très souvent
dans les dents des conférences pour
revoir pour parler du libre échange
mais le côté intéressant je pensais
dépasse largement sa et il résumé des
choses c'est en personnalisant personne
ne s'est fabriqué un crime effectivement
et c'est quelque chose d'assez frappant
et donc il faut une super intelligence
sociale pour fabriquer des crayons alors
après je suis d'accord que c'est quand
même quelque chose d'un peu particulier
cette forme de super intelligence dans
laquelle on baigne finalement je pense
l'objection que vous avez en tête
concernant le fait que c'est pas
vraiment ça la super intelligent sera
arrêté c'est qu'en fait c'est pas
vraiment un agent la société voilà ce
système c'est ce réseau de coopération
c'est pas un agent et qu'en pense à une
super intelligence on pense à un agent
super intelligent fait alors comme c'est
un peu peut-être obscurs comme que nos
objections j'ai précisé ce qu'on entend
par un agent donc l'idée c'est qu'un
agent c'est quelque chose qui a des
désirs des des préférences qui poursuit
des objectifs qui en outre à une
représentation du monde
un des croyances sur le monde et qui
agit conformément à ses croyances en vue
de réaliser ses préférences voilà ce
serait ça un agent et la question c'est
est ce que on peut considérer la société
comme un agent clairement retraite non
disons c'est compliqué c'est pas évident
on pourrait dans une certaine mesure on
aura dix ans et on regarde les choses de
suffisamment loin ça peut ressembler le
comportement d'une société on pourrait
peut-être l'assimiler au comportement
dans la jambe disons oui c'est par la
société américaine dans les années 60
vous voulez aller sur la lune et et
croyez que c'était possible prêt et que
le meilleur moyen d'arriver à ça c'était
de créer quelque chose comme l'avait
utilisé là la nasa est un programme
voilà on pourrait on pourrait décrire
les choses comme ça mais ça paraît pas
tout à fait on voit bien qu'en fait
quand on parle des préférences voilà un
tel niveau en fait c'est une façon
d'agréger des préférences individuelles
et
et clairement ça marchera pas toujours
très bien on sent bien que c'est pas un
agent bona fide et ben c'est pas c'est
pas un agent respectable si on s'en
remet quelque chose de bizarre
dontenville des choses bizarres c'est
que si on dit que c'est vrai on peut
dire de pourquoi pas il ya des
préférences juste voilà c'est une
majorité préfère abeba
voilà on pourrait dire que voilà c'est
ça la préférence mais bon ça pose un
problème qui est normalement chez un
agent on suppose une sorte de cohérence
une sorte d'unité qui fait que les
préférences vont être transitif dire si
je préfère la vanille au chocolat
chocolat pistache devait forcément
préparé la vanille à la pistache des
préférences agrégé elles n'ont pas cette
propriété cette belle propriété donc des
raisons pour lesquelles on sent bien
qu'il ya quelque chose de composites il
ya des agents dans un agent qui est
quelque chose qui va plus très bien
aller voilà donc on est d'accord ça
reste une super forme super intelligent
ça un peu bizarre et donc ok maintenant
on va parler dire ok bon voila j'ai
essayé de donner à ce concept de super
intelligent c'est un vernis tout à fait
respectable maintenant on va parler de
trucs un peu plus étranges
je vais commencer par celle de comment
commencer du coup j'ai mis ce petit
comique ce que j'ai trouvé assez drôle
sur le site white flight le blog de
steam
j'ai oublié l'auteur du blog think i
enfin bref donc c'est le blog white
bonne foi et en tout cas c'est c'est un
très bon blog réunion qu'il a consacré
de deux billets sur la super intelligent
c'est c'est eh
ils sont très intéressants et notamment
ce petit comics fait amusant et je ne
savais pas comment commencer ce passage
sur la super intelligence artificielle
donc voilà c'est un groupe
disons les êtres humains qui sont au
niveau à la station de tram intelligence
de niveau humain et qui voit arriver qui
voit arriver de l'iag à ce moment il ya
l'ia qui arrive le train de l'ia qui
arrivent il ya il arrive vite et hop
voilà donc c'est le train de l'ia ne
s'arrêtent même pas au niveau de la
station intelligence humaine et file
tout de suite au niveau super
intelligent bon alors quelle raison
aurait de de croire ça alors honnêtement
je ne fais pas tant que ça examiner les
raisons parce que je vais pas engager un
débat d'experts sur ces questions là
mais je peux déjà faire quelques
remarques qui est que l'on peut
décomposer ça honteux partie d'une part
ce qui est que il ya d'abord la question
de savoir dans quelle mesure ces
probables d'un que le train de l'ia
arrive déjà jusqu'à la station
intelligence humaine alors bien sûr
c'est important de décider formulé
samedi la cure ils sont intelligents
parce que dès qu'on formule les choses
en terme d'intelligence et du regain
pour dire mieux ça veut rien dire nous
disons simplement quelque chose comme un
stade presque toutes les tâches ne
peuvent réaliser les êtres humains
peuvent être réalisées au moins si le
classement par des machines là pour
l'instant ce n'est pas le cas sinon vous
auriez peut-être demander à une machine
de faire cette conférence pour l'instant
des êtres humains restent meilleurs au
moins à ce genre de trucs est ce qu'à un
moment donné on pourra sérieusement
toujours se poser la question moi je
sais faire ça par une machine d'un être
humain national à ce stade là ce serait
voilà le stade où le train de l'ia
arrive à la station intelligence humaine
et la deuxième question c'est celle du
delà du dépassement considère un niveau
super intelligent
ça paraîtrait un peu bizarre vraiment ça
s'arrête jamais on arrive à développer
quelque chose au-delà du niveau humain
de l'intelligence ans parce que dans les
domaines où on a l'intelligence
artificielle ah voilà avant ce bien
mince avance toujours au delà des
performances humaines aucune raison que
ce soit une limite fixe disons la
question savoir dans quelle mesure ça
c'est juste une question autour de la
cinétique de la progression après sa
série rescue durée une simplement une
amélioration progressive qui du coup
pourrait prendre vraiment beaucoup de
temps et avant qu'on puisse vraiment
légitimement par une super intelligent
ça serait vraiment très long et voilà on
comptera une explosion pour diverses
raisons notamment si on crée une
intelligence artificielle capable de de
s'améliorer elle même et d'être plus
efficace que n'importe quel être humain
pour s'améliorer elle même et on va lire
une sorte de renforcement positif qui
ferait une espèce d'explosion j'ai pas
spécialement
déjà c'est pas du tout mon domaine
en fait sur ces questions là j'aurais
simplement envie de savoir qu'est ce
qu'est le consensus auprès des experts
sur ces questions là c'est quelque chose
qui est assez difficile à connaître en
fait j'y reviendrai ville à la dernière
question qui est intéressante et c'est
là où vraiment j'ai pensé à ressembler
un fou c'est la question de la
probabilité de catastrophe mais genre
vraiment d énorme catastrophe liée à ces
super intelligent serait ya vraiment un
risque particulier lié à ces super
intelligence c'est super intelligence
artificielle et voilà qui est la
probabilité de ce que la strophe là et
qu'ils font courir vraiment ce que nick
boynton notamment appellent des crises
qui existentielle pour l'humanité c'est
à dire voilà une disparition de
l'humanité que je suis désolé de dire ça
alors face à face à tout ça il ya
vraiment beaucoup d'hostilité vis-à-vis
de d'auteurs comme nick bostrom
ou encore pirelli dukovski nom s'inspire
nine bostrom objectivement donc arrive
ni bostrom c'est toujours un peu
indirectement par les deux crocs qui il
ya vraiment une hostilité une très très
très
déclaré assez violente vis-à-vis de ces
choses là qui sont prises qui sont assez
vite évacué d'un revers de la main comme
étant des décharges la tannerie et des
spéculations sont sans aucun intérêt
alors en général l'objection le fond de
l'objection en général aussi toujours à
dire nés quelque part voilà sur ces deux
premières questions ses deux frères
probabilité c'est trop faible voilà
c'est faible
objectivement si on regarde ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui c'est pas crédible
ou alors est en fait souvent c'est
plutôt très difficile à évaluer
c'est plutôt ça c'est que c'est un tueur
un mélange de nommer regarder comment
voir google traduction vous direz si
vraiment vous avez peur des ia ou est
suivi de et toute façon si tout ça est
un peu plus compliqué que ça et
honnêtement on n'en sait rien voilà
c'est une espèce de mélange de ça et
tout ça qui voilà qui conduit
au final à sur la dernière question là
on s'en fout complètement parce que
voilà les points précédents en trail que
on s'en fout c'est vrai c'est quasi
religieux vous êtes des espèces de bout
en bout arrêté d'annoncer la fin du
monde et voilà et vous êtes un as far et
un guitariste jean il dire d'une part en
personnellement j'espère ne pas être à
charge
je suis pas expert sur c'est sur ces
questions là donc j'aimerais connaître
le consensus sur les deux premières
questions par exemple
et j'ai l'impression que c'est
extrêmement difficile de le connaître
par exemple typique monique ben bostrom
site d'aidé chic qui va des espèces de
sondages qu'il fait dans différents
colloques sur sur ces deux premières
questions euros et mais bon c'est
toujours un peu douteux parce que il n'y
a pas énormément de répondant on peut se
demander si ce qui vraiment se
désintéresse totalement de boston n'ont
pas tendance à nous tout simplement pas
répondre ce qui pourrait expliquer
pourquoi les les chiffres qu'il donne
sont en général relativement optimiste
je veux dire par là qu'il donne quoi
inviter à ses hôtes à ces deux choses là
et j'ai l'impression le seul consensus
sur ces affaires de prédiction en
silence et artificielle c'est que en
incisant artificiel on est globalement
nul pour faire des prédictions c'est à
dire qu'il y ait eu des prédictions des
d'une prédiction tout 13 erronée dans un
sens comme dans l'autre c'est à dire
qu'il est deschamps qui paraissait très
très prometteur ça on aurait prédit que
ça allez vous développer mais en fait
pas du tout et à l'inversé des choses
qui semblaient lente et difficile mais
en fait ont été débloqués brusquement
donc le s'il ya un consensus sur le fait
que globalement les des prédictions sont
pas très fiables et quelque part ça
c'est difficile à évaluer
et du coup en fait parce que j'aurai
envie de répondre à ce genre de critique
c'est que la seule raison pour laquelle
il faudrait vraiment qu'ils les
probabilités présidente soit
extraordinaire non négligeable pour ce
soit pas un tout petit peu intéressant
de s'intéresser au troisième point
le troisième point c'est vraiment le
coeur du livre de bostrom typiquement
est vraiment le cadre de sa réflexion
et voilà la seule raison pour laquelle
on pouvait voir ce serait légitime de
dire ok vraiment on s'en fout ça si
c'était vraiment totalement négligeable
si c'est pas totalement négligeable
c'est au moins intéressant de se pencher
sur la question
donc voilà les bostrom jamais en train
de dire qu'il ait jamais en train
d'annoncer quelque chose est juste en
train de dire c'est c'est relativement
probable en tout cas c'est pas une
probabilité qui est totalement
négligeable du coup ben réfléchissons
aux y ait d'autres raisons encore mais
voilà déjà appris aussi sli probabilités
ne sont pas négligeables
ça vaut le coup d'y de réfléchir à ces
questions là et effectivement je pense
que justement parce que c'est très
difficile à évaluer
bah c'est pas négligeable dire que c'est
totalement impossible séance et faire
une prédiction qui est
beaucoup plus précise que toutes les
prédictions phoenix bostrom en fait dire
vraiment ça n'arrivera jamais c'est tout
à fait fantaisiste où ça s'est vraiment
faire un pari sur l'avenir qui est bien
plus incertain que le pari que fait
ningbo sera au centre lui ne dit jamais
autre chose que ces projets une certaine
probabilité de ceux ci en ont profité de
cela il n'est pas spécialement optimiste
par exemple le typiquement sur le fait
d'arriver à une nuit à deux niveaux
humain il est plutôt pessimiste par
rapport en tout cas par rapport aux
chercheurs qui consultaient île située
plutôt dans la tranche des plus
pessimistes
donc voilà donc tout ça pour me mettre
un peu à couvert dire à partir du moment
où vous acceptez que c'est pas
négligeable les deux premières
probabilités et je j'ai l'impression
qu'on sérieux plutôt rationnel de
considérer que c'est pas négligeable
du coup ça devient intéressant
s'intéresser à la troisième quand même
même si un peu le risque de passer pour
un fou parce que là c'est envisager des
situations très compliquées
disons alors je vais j'ai changé un peu
plus dans le livre de niveaux sera réglé
je pense beaucoup de choses très
intéressantes dans les deux niveaux ce
train de tourner autour de cette
distinction entre objectifs finaux et
objectifs instrumentaux enfin on
pourrait traduire autrement
choisissez père me la fait pas mal donc
intuitivement s'avérait compliqué l'idée
c'est l'objectif final c'est vraiment le
truc que l'indigence de rechercher un
petit musée a réalisé la fonction qui va
chercher à maximiser par exemple et ça
peut être très complexe pris le set ça
pourrait être extraordinairement
complexe évidemment c'est pas censé
parfois aussi j'ai mis le kit universal
pays pour ceux qui connaissent ça lui
fera pas de vous connaissez le un petit
jeu en ligne autour de ça c'est de taper
universel paperclip sont tombés sur un
petit jeu en ligne sont amusants ou on
essaye de maximiser le nombre de public
dans l'univers par exemple le nom de
trombone dans l'univers et on finit par
mois je vous parle pas de savourer ça
tourne ça tombe très mal forcément donc
cela peut être une fonction de ce type
là
mais évidemment c'est plutôt caricatural
et complexe et puis donc la notion
d'objectif instrumentaux l'idée c'est
que bon bah étant donné à certaines
objectif final je peux avoir certaines
croyances sur le monde qui font que je
vais de façon instrumentale poursuivre
un autre objectif parce que par exemple
je crois que réaliser l'objectif à
[Musique]
maximiser par rapport à toutes les
autres choses que je pourrais faire
maximise la probabilité de satisfaire
mon objectif final
du coup satisfaire l'objectif à devient
un objectif pour moi un objectif
voilà simplement instrumentale en plus
de réaliser cet objectif final alors là
la première thèse que défend nick
bostrom la défendent en ces termes là
c'est un peu prétentieux sa façon de
nommer chou test de leurs togolaise
d'ortho gones aly t il veut dire par là
à ce moment donc je suis intelligent ses
objectifs finaux sont orthogonaux plus
ou moins n'importe quel niveau
d'intelligence pourrait en principe être
combiné avec plus ou moins n'importe
quel objectif final je sais pas si je
suis tout à fait d'accord mais je vous
en fait c'est plutôt une raison de ne
pas trop s'inquiéter parce qu'en fait ce
serait très inquiétant si c'était pas le
cas si c'est en fait dire que c'est pas
qu'à ça reviendra à dire que aller un
certain niveau d'intelligence finalement
bas poursuit débute super intelligent
voilà si vous êtes intelligent vous se
poursuivre et les buts intelligent une
sorte de créer une sorte de d'émergence
d'objectifs finaux qui seraient liés à
des niveau d'intelligence outre que je
sais pas bien ce que ça pourrait vouloir
dire c'est pas con qu'on devient trop
d'intelligence mais a fixé le vide
existentiel à écrire des poèmes ou des
sauts comme ça parce que vraiment bien
trop intelligent ça devient un but
forcément bon je sais pas si c'est très
crédible mais surtout en fait ce serait
assez terrifiant parce que ça voudrait
dire qu'en fait bon là vraiment il ya
rien à faire face à une super
intelligence le super intelligent soirée
débute super intelligent et il y aurait
vraiment aucun moyen de 2
de dire que ce soit pertinent à son
sujet du coup donc j'ai envie dire c'est
presque un pari plutôt optimiste en fait
dire que quelque part on peut quand même
essayer de réfléchir une super
intelligent ce notamment grâce à ça
parce que on peut supposer que même une
super intelligence on pourrait lui un
peu le elle pourrait poursuivre des buts
qui qui sont compréhensibles par un être
humain parce que finalement il ya ce
principe d'auto banalité pourrez suivre
en fait n'importe quel but maximiser le
nombre de deux coups trombone dans
l'univers ou tout à fait autre chose et
voilà donc on pourrait se dire il suffit
du coup ben voilà pour ne pas avoir de
problème avec une super intelligent s'il
fallait lui donner des objectifs finaux
sympa acceptable par l'humanité voilà
qui nous mettent pas en danger vous
pourrez dire voilà bonne nouvelle c'est
bon c'est réglé mais voilà l'essentiel
des difficultés dans le livre de nick
bostrom tourne autour de 2 à ce que
j'appelle le point deux objectifs
instrumentaux qui est en gros comment
garantir que les objectifs instrumentaux
qu'une super intelligence poursuit sont
acceptables
je vais comprendre que les objectifs
dans son manteau voilà même si vous
comprenez l'objectif final que poursuit
une serveuse un super intelligence le
président et même de super intelligence
implique les objectifs instrumentaux
qu'elle est susceptible de poursuivre
pour réaliser cet objectif final sont
pas forcément compréhensible super
intelligent sans qu'une fois vous
représentez vous ça comme nord dont les
représentations tout à l'heure ben il y
avait certaines de ces la dernière
représentation de la super intelligent
ce que je suggérais était celle du super
intelligent ce dans des dimensions de
l'espace supérieure à 3 au sens où elle
peut poursuivre des objectifs
instrumentaux qui sont tout à fait
inconcevable qu'on n'arrivait même pas à
comprendre qu'ils sont et c'est le
propre même d'une super intelligent ce
que voilà donc pas prévoir par avance le
cheval la séquence d'objectif en ce
moment tout grâce auquel va arriver à
son objectif final parce que si on
pouvait le faire mais on sait aussi
intelligente qu'elle s'est un petit peu
ça quelque part
l anti gens seraient trouvés
le trajet optimal parmi les objets dans
les objectifs instrumentaux de quelque
part une super intelligence forcément
est susceptible dessus des trajets
ceux-ci son action comme une espèce de
trajet comme ça dans les objectifs en ce
moment tous qu'elle suit qui passerait
par des eaux totalement invisible pour
ainsi dire pour moi inconcevable et du
coup ça ça pose à bath et ça posera oula
ça s'est arrêté à ce que continue au
micro je me sentais puissant qui bon
voilà alors tout de même on peut savoir
peut-être deux ou trois choses
concernant les objectifs instrumentaux
que poursuivre et une intelligence
artificielle et c'est un autre thème qui
est très intéressant dans le texte
bostrom qui est l'idée de de convergence
des convergences des objectifs
instrumentaux on peut se dire que pour
un vaste ensemble de 2,2 fin de
d'objectifs finaux que poursuivre est
super intelligent ce à moins d'écarter
ses objectifs ses objectifs et
instrumentaux vers laquelle ça a
tendance à converger
ça aura tendance à aller dans cette
direction là alors quels sont ses
objectifs
instrumentaux qui qui sont en compte
dans lequel la super intelligent trice
de converger c'est premièrement l'auto
préservation si vous donnez un objectif
c'est voilà dit pas typiquement pour
rester dans mon exemple des paper clipse
si vous dites maximiser le nombre de
pépites dans l'univers
donc le nombre de trombone la première
des choses c'est éviter de disparaître
parce que si je disparais j'ai pas de
raison de penser que quelqu'un
poursuivra la continuera de mettre en
oeuvre cet objectif là probablement sa
maximisera pas le nom de trombone dans
l'univers de la première des choses
c'est voilà se préserver
deuxième chose ça c'est un truc
intéressant c'est préserver ses
objectifs instrumentaux ou même c'est à
dire que éviter de vue que l'on m'impose
d'autres objectifs instrumentaux le
pardon d'autres objectifs finaux
préserver les objectifs finaux
voilà je pense le genre de truc un peu
étrange c'est difficile on apprécie le
pense et ça même ce qu'est ce que par
exemple est ce qu'on refuserait c'est
pas par exemple de en fait moi tant pis
si la question serait par exemple est-ce
qu'on vous voulez vous est-ce qu'on peut
vouloir vouloir quelque chose qu'on ne
veut pas là maintenant
quelque part ce genre de choses c'est
pas totalement en dehors des choses
qu'on est capable de vouloir par
certains côtés donc voilà on imagine à
il ya un an
[Musique]
une super intelligent ce qu'il kiffe
voilà qui tu veux remplir le monde de
trombone lui il n'en est pas ce genre de
considérations là il veut continuer de
vouloir remplir le monde entier truman
parce qu'évidemment si si si on lui
change cet objectif final basso ne
maximisent pas qu'ils combattent dans
l'univers donc une bonne façon de
maximiser le nom du trombone de
l'univers aussi c'est de faire en sorte
qu'il continue de deux de vouloir faire
un maximum remplir l'univers d'un
maximum de trombone et n'aurait d'autre
je les présente plus vite l'idée se
perfectionner aussi voilà de devenir
meilleur dans l'art de faire des
trombones évidemment c'est une bonne
façon de maximiser notre modèle univers
aussi et puis à acquérir un maximum de
ressources donc voilà pour pouvoir faire
de sercus de trombone ou pouvoir
calculer plus vite pour voir mieux se
perfectionner mes yeux réalisé les
autres fans il ya de bonnes raisons pour
lesquelles on peut supposer que un peu
par défaut on a envie de dire une super
intelligent aurait tendance à poursuivre
ses fins là est le problème avec ces
fins la sécu en fait de façon
instrumentale
une bonne façon de les réaliser
notamment les deux premières qu'il est
plus grand danger dans ce cas qu'est le
danger simplement dire là pour du point
de vue de notre intérêt super
intelligence qui fabrique des trombones
le de réfléchir la situation il a dit à
un moment donné ils auront assez de
trombone les êtres humains ils vont ils
vont me débrancher le principal obstacle
du coup à la préservation de soi ou à
l'intégrité de ses objectifs finaux
c'est de supprimer l'espèce humaine
il est difficile d'imaginer une épouse à
s'effacer
voilà je voulais que ça reste c'est un
peu raté en tout cas voilà l'idée c'est
que de danser ses objectifs
instrumentaux vers laquelle le
comportement de la super intelligent se
convergent les listes dans beaucoup de
cas de faire en sorte que l'extinction
des espèces humaines deviennent elles
mêmes un objet un objectif instrumentale
et c'est là où on semble dire que et
c'est un peu ce que didier effectivement
bostrom que bell l'apocalypse d'une
sorte de voile à de résultats par défaut
faire que une super intelligence sauf si
elle est sauf si on a fait en sorte
d'éviter ça risque de mener à cette très
déplaisantes
ce très déplaisant résultat qui est ce
qui serait que l'espèce humaine serait
éliminé alors vous dire mais c'est une
machine n'avait pas supprimé toute
espèce humaine comme ça alors c'est là
que coup de fiction autour d'eux c'est à
dire j'arrête ma depuis tout à l'heure
vous parler de cette histoire de
trombone et c'est typiquement les
fictions qui sont racontés dans ce genre
de texte parce que leur nature envie
d'illustrer sa part par des fictions et
c'est vrai que ces flics sur la elles
ont quelque chose de complètement
fantaisistes cesser complètement
étranger notant par exemple sur comment
est-ce que comment est ce qu'elle
détruise l'espèce humaine tout à coup
pour mieux encore enfin voix pour
satisfaire cet objectif instrumental qui
est de préserver de se préserver
donc ok très étrange je donne un petit
extrait de
du livre de neil bostrom qui cite en
fait un pas qui synthétise un passage de
youtube ski qui décrit un scénario de
steve pelade comment est ce que une
super intelligence prendrait le pouvoir
et supprimerait tous les êtres humains
le scénario parce que toutes sortes mais
bon là c'est très souvent comme ça c'est
tout cas base de nanorobots qui voilà
donc une super intelligent ce qui crée
des nanorobots désormais nanorobots qui
tue tout le monde ça c'est toujours des
trucs comme ça et c'est là que j'ai
envie de vraiment de rappeler ce
principe on a vu qu'ils aient que un
auteur déjà voilà un personnage de
fiction n'est jamais plein de fusion que
son auteur est donc là le personnage de
fiction la super intelligent d'une lutte
comme ce qui n est pas plus intelligent
que young cox quitte donc pour une cause
qui voilà le scénario puis qu'il est
capable de trouver pour ça c'est
celui-là est quelque part il est
ridicule je suis d'accord enfin il a un
côté ridicule mais c'est c'est c'est
normal c'est si vous laisser aussi
ridicule que ça devait passer c'est
aussi ridicule que voilà que la façon
dont dont jules verne ou cyrano de
bergerac envisage la face on essaie
d'aller sur la lune est ridicule c'est
normal effectivement peut-être un
lecteur de vous pensez vraiment que l'on
peut aller sur la lune cette façon là en
fait la bonne réponse était de dire non
mais je pense qu'on peut aller sur la
lune quand même et la même façon on a
beau dire il faut pas se focaliser sur
la les moyens qui sont décrits même si
bon c'est très tentant parce que c'est
là ça ressemble à un scénario de
science-fiction objectivement et mais
c'est plutôt le but lui même dire que
quelque part comprendre par quels moyens
on pourrait aller sur la lune
il crée des fictions crédible là dessus
on n'a pas pu le faire avant d'être plus
ou moins en mesure d'aller sur la lune
de la même façon écrire une fiction
crédible de comment est-ce qu'une super
intelligence pourrait tuer tous les
êtres humains et voilà c'est voilà
c'était les vraies élections crédibles
autour de ça alice de précédé de peu la
disparition des êtres humains en tout
cas en tout cas voilà les moyens mis en
oeuvre pour pour pour ça ce sont
forcément dans l'imagination de nos deux
clubs ce qui très en dessous de ce
qu'ils seraient réellement de même façon
que les moyens mis en oeuvre pour aller
sur la lune ils sont très en dessous
dans l'imagination du verne qui est
pourtant riche et voilà et souvent
informées scientifiquement mais voilà ce
n'est pas avec un gros canon qu'on
allait aller sur la lune savais que tout
à fait autre chose et c'est pas pour
autant que ce n'était pas possible
d'aller sur la lune justement on peut
faire le lien avec cette idée de super
intelligence sociale souvent c'est parce
que typiquement aller sur la lune a
requis cette super intelligence sociale
on pouvait pas prévoir comment c'est
notre super intelligence sociale allait
résoudre ce problème de aller sur la
lune n'était pas vraiment prévisible va
un auteur comme jules verne à une époque
comme celle vous décrivez voilà on fait
face à la même difficulté je pense
lorsqu'on essaie d'envisager de quelle
façon une super intelligent se ferait
ceci ou cela sans que je pense à la
comparaison avec la fiction est
intéressante
bon j'approche de la conclusion ça fait
combien de temps l'air comment ça fait
une heure ça tombe bien je suis pas très
confiant je suis désolé c'est j'avais
dit enfin je lui dis un peu près une
heure donc quand on parle de super
intelligent si on fait vraiment face à
ce qu'on pourrait appeler un brouillard
épistémique c'est-à-dire épistémique cet
arrêt forcé à prendre connaissance
soumis un brouillard de connaissances et
vous voulez l'absence de connaissance il
a il ya deux couses dans ce brouillard
si j'ose dire la première touche qui
concerne justement la probabilité que
toutes ces considérations là soit
pertinent c'est effectivement on fasse
un jour face à une super infusion
première couche de brouillard et elle
est vraiment et pèse déjà cette première
plus je bruyère je pense et je veux dire
le fait qu'elle soit épaisse ne diminue
pas l'intérêt de la suite parce que
justement dans un brouillard épais il
peut se cacher des choses
impressionnantes et la deuxième couche
de brouillard épais qui concerne le
comportement même de ce qu'ils
pourraient s'y cacher jusqu'au bout hier
à savoir un possibilité de concevoir les
moyens d'action d'agents super
intelligent du coup grosses difficultés
à envisager comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait
design est une forme de contrôle quand
même pour penser à ces choses là et
voilà et tout ça associé à cette
probabilité non négligeable tout de même
qu'un agent ce super intelligent
poursuivre en tant qu'objectif
instrumental un objectif à son mental
pour nos intérêts de l'humanité et c'est
un petit peu effrayant du coup forcément
et c'est là où on passe pour l'espèce
d'illuminer catastrophisme ce que je
voudrais pas encore une fois parce que
je trouve ces questions sont
intellectuellement ne serait-ce qu
intellectuellement intéressante samedi
j'ai passé juste sur ce point là il y
aura une façon de contourner le
brouillard épistémique celui de trouver
une sorte de deux raisons d'être un peu
moins crise et j'aime beaucoup ce
principe là dans le livre denis glostrup
il appelle de principe de déférence
épistémique juste venir parce qu'il est
bien formulé une future super
intelligent s'occupent un point de vue
et puis c'est évidement supérieur d'un
point de vue épistémique mans supérieur
ses croyances probablement sur la
plupart des sujets ont plus de chances
d'être vrai que les nôtres nous devrions
donc nous en remettre à l'opinion que la
superbe de la supervision à chaque fois
que c'est possible ça veut dire quoi et
qu'est ce qu'ils en tirent de cette idée
là c'est que global au hockey une super
intelligent c'est pour y poursuivre des
phares à son mental d'autant plus
terrifiante qu'on peut pas les
comprendre mais il faut aussi se dire
que voilà le principe même d'une super
exigence c'est que ces capacités sont
meilleurs que les nôtres dont en tous
domaines et notamment par exemple dans
le domaine consisterait à comprendre ce
qui est dans notre intérêt ou pas et
donc ce que suggère ce principe de
déférence et de dire quelque part plutôt
qu'essayer de d'imaginer ce qui est
notre intérêt est d'essayer de chez pas
de
de contrôler une super intelligent selon
lui donnant des buts qui sont conformes
à nos intérêts d'après ce que nous
comprenons nos intérêts se dire que
finalement la compréhension même nos
intérêts est une tâche à laquelle la
super intelligent c'est meilleur que
nous et donc déferré cette tâche là une
super intelligente forme de stratégie qu
un peu étonnante qui n'est pas évidente
à première vue est qui et qui semble
assez en tout cas que nick dos quand tu
défends et qui semble voilà assez
logique en fait quand on comprend ce
qu'est une super intelligent c'est
précisément effectivement même la
compréhension du propre intérêt
finalement je suis moins bon allez
comprendre que qu'une su hypothétique
super intelligence et voilà donc je sais
ça fait juste revenir sur ces sur ce
brouillard épistémique en ajoutant du
coup de deux petites
de petites remarques la première c'est
que il ya sa comptabilité non
négligeable qu'un agent super des gens
poursuivre un objectif à son mental
contraire entre l humanité mais il ya
aussi une probabilité non négligeable
que des précautions prises par des
agents intelligents de prises vatry
intelligemment pas besoin d'une super
intelligence diminue dans une certaine
mesure la probabilité précédente et
aussi par ailleurs augmenterait pour
éviter que les effets ne se parlent des
gens soient plutôt de positif du coup
c'est important s'il souligne et ça ça
donne une autre raison pour laquelle
c'est pas juste une simple vue de
l'esprit de s'intéresser à voilà aux
effets potentiels d'une super
intelligent s'il peut il ya aussi avoir
c'est cette dimension là et elle est
vraiment très présente chez j bostrom
mais encore une fois on est dans un
cadre très probable il pas en train de
dire voilà ce qu'il faut faire pour
sauver l'humanité illustre réfléchir à
des éventualités plus ou moins probable
et voilà et je rajouterais que il est
difficile de parler à tout ça sans avoir
complètement l'air d'un flou et c'est
dommage parce que des sujets qui sont je
pense qu'on méritait vraiment une
réflexion une réflexion justement pas
papa de voilà
je vais pas annoncer l'apocalypse je
vais pas rationnel posé et froide si
possible et c'est pas qui c'est fait
face c'est faire face à des choses
tellement énorme que c'est assez
difficile mais ça vaut le coup voilà
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci thibault du coup on peut passer
aux questions si vous avez des questions
parmi d'anciens jeux
alors c'est bon je pense tatatata pas
encore assez bon c'est là vous avez
rendu oui ah pardon
le thème
typiquement les lois de limoges sera un
mauvais exemple parce que c'est d'abord
un car nous on essaye de spécifier
qu'est ce qui est dans l'intérêt de
l'humanité et voilà les machines passent
leur temps à trouver des loups paul dans
ces trucs là il ya plein d'exemples
comme ça dans de si votre homme je suis
par exemple vous dites maximiser le
bonheur de l'humanité par exemple comme
but final ça peut pas mal tourné sont
qui s'abat en fait réduire les militants
d'esclavagé dans un état d'euphorie
perpétuelle c'est la meilleure façon de
maximiser le c'est une façon économique
donc il n'y aurait pas de raisons pas le
faire de façon économique on peut
vraiment voilà donc remplir l'univers
des trucs de légumes historique
vous pourrez devenir ça serait
typiquement ce serait le genre de choses
qu'on éviterait donc oui je pense que
j'en ai envisagé vers la fin avec ses
vers la fin du livre de deux bostrom
notamment eu un concept qui je vais
passer vite mais comme ça qu'on va
devenir impossible que étudie bostrom
comme comme façons possibles essayé de
circonscrire cette une façon jugement de
faire en sorte que la super intelligence
agissent conformément aux intérêts de
l'humanité mais sans essayer de en
déférant a en lui des faits rend la
tâche de déterminer ce qui est dans
l'intérêt de l'humanité que l'étranger
donc réveillé cette formule de 2,8 comme
ski
vous laisse lire qui consiste voilà
cette notion de cohérente extrapole les
titres volition avec l'idée donc de
demander une donnée comme but final
quelque chose qui serait de maximiser sa
plutôt que maximiser voilà quelque chose
comme le bonheur dd conforme ou quelque
chose de précis en fait c'est assez
facile même juste avec notre
intelligence qui n'est pas pape a cité
que ça de trouver indécent de lourdes
qui font que voilà il ya un moyen de
maximiser sa qui est qui et pas du tout
ce qu'on avait en tête lorsqu'on veut
donner le lorsque vous voulez ça voilà
oui bonjour et plusieurs points sur
évoluent juste commenté c'est à dire le
sur la partie augmentation du de la
sphère des choses concevable finalement
l'une des dimensions supplémentaires
c'est le temps quant aux parts du
chasseur cueilleur il ya cent mille ans
qui pourront serait une super
intelligence pour lui finalement c'est
le temps les itérations de
l'apprentissage qui a permis d'
d'atteindre d'aller marcher sur la lune
et
et ça me fait penser à la conférence de
michel serres sur l'apprentissage sur le
savoir la transmission du savoir
c'est à dire qu'il ya différentes
révolution cognitive dans l'humanité
avec la capacité à communiquer par les
l'écriture l'imprimerie est aujourd'hui
la possible d'avoir le savoir tout de
suite sur le sur les terminaux pour ne
plus avoir à se remémorer donc ça laisse
ça libère des ressources cognitives pour
faire d'autres choses et aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle j'ai pas
l'impression qu'elle a encore cette
capacité à pouvoir transmettre du savoir
entre elles pouvoir
créer du social et là l'intelligence de
groupe qui permet à l'homme d'aller
marcher sur la lune cercle un seul à le
faire mais la capacité que la groupe
peut apprendre ensemble pour pouvoir en
se spécialisant les uns les autres comme
on a eu l'intelligence d'une fourmilière
qui est largement qui dépasse largement
la capacité cognitive d'une fourmi donc
et c'est vrai que dans l'artificiel
aujourd'hui j'en avais déjà discuté avec
les il n'ya pas encore cette capacité d
intelligence j'ai l'impression à
communiquer entre elles pour pouvoir
apprendre et échanger
réponse ce que je veux dire c'est qu'en
fait les machines aujourd'hui machine je
le redis communique déjà beaucoup plus
que nous elles sont tout le temps sur
internet en train de s'envoyer des
messages de caisse et un peu difficile
de dire qu'elle communique pas comme
messi s'il ya du machine learning d'une
machine learning fayat ya déjà beaucoup
de d'optimisation qui est fait alors ses
pattes des trucs phares sont très
sophistiqués mais il ya déjà des
machines qui communiquent les unes avec
les autres c'est pas un truc qui est
spécifique à l'humain je pense juste à
cet âge ou si je peux me permettre sur
la société peut-elle être quand c'est
considéré comme un agent
ouais en fait on je sais si on peut
peut-être à petit les choses par les
jeux mais on a un théorème qu'il dit que
oui si elle résolve le consensus
une société qui résultent consensus est
une société qui a au moins le même
agencement que ces individus parce que
en fait des machines de turenne qui ait
résolu le consensus simule une machine
de turing ensemble il y a des
préférences
cyclique c'est déjà ça c'est vraiment un
peu une condition pour considérer que
quelque chose est un agent qui n'est pas
ce genre de cas qui est pas quelque
chose comme des préférences en tout cas
là le crawl abritait d'être un agent
d'un individu n'est pas perdu et meuf
l'école c'était de calcul sont augmentés
si les individus ensemble résolve le
consensus
je pense tu vas contredit si je me
trompe mais que tu faisais référence au
thunder au fait que donc le terme
d'argot dit qu'on peut pas agrégée des
préfets des préférences individuelles
avec certaines propriétés de monotonie
citer tous sur la côte
c'est ça fait penser merci d'être venu
organiser cette conférence ça fait très
plaisir d'avoir des thématiques comme
axe discuter merci je pose une question
du rythme est un peu c'est un peu
différent
on a beaucoup parlé des super
intelligent ski accomplirait du coût des
tâches commandes et enfin pour
l'humanité commandé par l'humanité est
ce qu on pourrait aussi penser à
l'observer visiter c'est hyper
intelligent c'est ce que par exemple en
observant hyper intelligence accomplir
une tâche on peut en apprendre plus sur
la tâche ou même sur l'humanité en
elle-même sur nous mêmes on a déjà
quelques exemples je sais pas si en
observant alpha govou exemple
les joueurs de go parce qu'ils ont un
peu appris besoin c'est très tellement
opaques qu'on a pas tellement
l'impression qu'ils aient appris
énormément comparé à l'avancé que c'est
en y avait quelque chose
joueur de go artificielle qui équipe le
bac il est plus grands tubes champions
ça a fait énormément progresser la
compréhension du go par les joueurs de
gros cela je n'ai pas eu l'impression
que c'est plus un truc qui concerne les
joueurs de go eux-mêmes je pensais les a
fascinés métier peat moss est très
opaque
tout ce qu'ils ont c'est les coups
qu'ils jouent quasiment et c'est
toujours assez frappant dans toutes ces
questions voilà ou après la classe zéro
qui joue aux échecs je puisse regarder
ces trucs là parce que ça je suis plus
joueur d'échecs au jour 2 go et jeu dès
que vous super surprenant et ben on
l'est face aux coups surprenant et des
bas c'est surprenant et apparemment on
peut gagner en jouant comme ça et on ne
savait pas mais subissent man ray on n'a
pas l'impression que c'est facilement
observables ce qui se passe de choses
alors une autre question
enfin je demandais c'était vraiment
souhaitable que il ya une intelligence
artificielle
enfin en simple ont une super
intelligent ce qui nous dépasse
largement
parce que pour prendre un exemple simple
parlons de congé aux échecs
j'ai pas enfin si julia intelligence
afin de super intelligent ce qui me dit
qu'elle coup joué quelques hauts et le
meilleur ça ça m'intéresse pas vraiment
tu préférais faire comme le coup que moi
je pense être le meilleur en tout cas je
n'ai pas envie de jouer un coup qui
aurait enfin sur lequel je sais pas
pourquoi ce serait le meilleur donc
d'une certaine manière
tout ce que je tout ce qui est en dehors
de mon intelligence tout ce que je peux
pas réussir à comprendre pourquoi je
ferais ça n'aurait aucun intérêt pour
moi
donc est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas une
sorte un peu de limites au niveau de ce
qui nous intéresse d'un point de vue
d'assumer intelligence il ya deux et
deux types de tâches qu'on pourrait
vouloir faire qu'on joue aux échecs on
peut vouloir s'amuser en jouant aux
échecs dans ce cas effectivement ça sert
à rien d'être avoir un logiciel qui vous
dit qu'elle peut jouer depuis la tâche
consiste à dire à jouer le meilleur coût
et à ce moment là oui c'est sarah
quelque chose d'avoir à l'ordinateur qui
me conseillent voir en fait nous laisser
totalement là
jouez à votre place donc voilà ça fait
très longtemps que les ordinateurs très
longtemps j'ai pas plus d'une décennie
que les ordinateurs j'ai pu vraiment
l'attention d'une meilleure le match
d'ibm ibm c'était 80 97
voilà ça fait vingt ans c'est pas pour
autant qu'on joue aux échecs
parce que justement le but de deux
joueurs d'échecs c'est avant tout de
s'amuser on vend à ce jeu là donc je
pense que ça ça diminue pas l'intérêt du
jeu le fait qu' il a été résolu par les
eaux l'urd quelques idées même les jeux
qui ont été résolues on continue à y
jouer il ya des gens fois que le jeu de
dames est vraiment résolu entre comme ça
encore jouer au jeu de dames n'a pas
effectivement si vous voulez gagner si
votre objectif c'est de gagner
utiliser un programme qu'il a résolu
c'est plus c'est pas amusant mais je
vais dire ma vie et genre de question
qu'un passant par exemple imaginer que
vraiment parmi les tâches auxquelles un
être humain est meilleure qu'à 90 ils en
seraient meilleurs que nous c'est par
exemple à partir d'une idée de roman
écrire un roman
voilà moi si j'ai une idée de roman je
vais passer un an dessus je vais en
tirer un roman l'a imaginé qui est qui
celui-ci donné cette idée des
indications de style peut-être même
s'inspirer de votre propre style quelque
chose comme ça et ça produirait un roman
un roman tel que vous l'auriez écrit
d'une certaine façon en tout cas assez
ressemblant et peut-être même bien
meilleure parce que vous auriez fait
peut-être réglé le la qualité est ce que
est ce qu'on continuerait d'écrire des
romans en tant qu'être humain je ressens
ça sera un petit peu de la même pas de
la même façon que l'on continue de deux
pas de le pourrir
alors que l'on peut prendre la voiture
juste parce que c'est agréable
face aux grands vides 2
écrire un roman vous même si bon c'est
un petit peu old school de faire ça
passe objectivement c'est oublier juste
avoir le roman écrit vous pourriez
utiliser une machine adéquate
mais voilà pourquoi pas le faire parce
que c'est agréable de l'écrire je sais
pas si j'ai bien répondu à votre
question mais finalement ce serait pas
mieux de détacher une super intelligence
d et finalement ce serait pas mieux de
détacher en fait les objectifs finaux
d'une super intelligence des objectifs
qui sont directement liés au bien-être
de l'humanité l'humanité parce que si on
y réfléchit
si on avait faim de maximiser le bonheur
d'humanité on a envie aussi de réduire
le malheur paraît logique
puis si on a envie de réduire le malheur
des gens dont on pourrait tous les tuer
[Musique]
ce soit clair que le bonheur est une
donnée positive elle me dit que le
malheur n'est pas une donnée une donnée
nul est positive mais justement
typiquement vous je pense qu'on comprend
très mal comment est-ce qu'on quantifie
même notre espèce d'utilitarisme club
primaire de un peu schématique
c'est très complexe comment est-ce qu'on
quantifie d'aidé pratique une bonne
heure pour faire des calculs du titre je
pense clairement je veux pas très bon je
pense que les espèces pas très bon pour
comprendre comment est ce qu'ils font
ces raisonnements ses raisonnements
je pense qu'il faudrait pas essayer
d'implémenter l'utilitarisme dans une
magistrale cuir des choses très
clairement d'accord alors attendu voilà
un ma question c'est si l'humanité
venait à disparaître à cause unia est-ce
que vu que l'ia est une création de
l'homme elle serait finalement la
continuation de l'espèce humaine
oui oui parce que ce serait si grave
merci pour cette conférence déjà et je
ma question ce serait
est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer une sorte
de fusion de l'être humain avec la super
intelligence dans le sens où intégrer
nos buts finaux à une super intelligent
ce afin d'avoir les outils super
intelligent à réalisation de nos propres
volontés en fait une sorte de
continuation de l'homme dans la super
intelligence trop de la science fiction
et je suis pas du tout compétent pour
répondre à cette question et bien
qu'arnaud très clairement sais pas si tu
as envie de dire quelque chose
aujourd'hui j'ai fait revient et si on
limitait le degré de deux crises inès de
tout ça a suffisamment de voix lors et
encore merci pour conférence est alors
c'est une question d'un super
intelligence est-ce qu'on va s'en servir
plutôt comme un outil puisque vous
entendre on n'est vraiment pas si
intelligent que ça est-ce qu'on va juste
s'en servir comme un outil
d'optimisation ou est ce que vous pensez
qu'on va en faire autre chose au delà
juste de gérer les chiffres
[Musique]
niveau stream sur cette cette idée là
l'idée de faux ça serait pas dangereux
si c'était juste un outil est en fait
c'est très difficile d'établir une
distinction entre une haute idée de ce
qu'est ce que c'est juste un outil et
une intelligence qui disposent pas parce
que si c'est juste un outil que peut
vraiment prévoir totalement
c'est ce que de quelle façon elle va
atteindre les objectifs pour lui de pour
lesquels on utilise comme outil on est
passé une super intelligent si on
comprend ce qui se passe en somme c'est
qu'on n'est pas facile non sucré
intelligent ça serait ça l'idée donc
faut accepter que si on ne fait face à
une super intelligent ce que voilà que
l'utiliser comme un outil c'est accepter
qu'à un moment donné ce qu'ils se
fassent passer dedans on n'a aucune idée
et voilà je pense et à ce moment là
c'est plus vraiment c'est plus vraiment
ce qu'on appelle un outil une dimension
de de créativité au sens vraiment que
nous-mêmes n'aurions pas pu trouver la
méthode par laquelle tout cet outil va
atteindre l'objectif que cambon qu'on
lui donne et appartements on a ça je
sais pas s'il parlait d' outil est
vraiment bizarre de parler beauty à ce
moment là merci déjà pour une conférence
ensuite je vois que vous n'êtes pas
expert de science fiction mais je me
demandais un petit peu sur les questions
philosophiques
parce que moi ce qui me fait le plus
peur c'est pas l'annihilation physique
de l'espèce humaine par unien mais
plutôt son âme ni enfin l'annihilation
de l'esprit mme parce que si on repose
tout le potentiel intellectuel sur
ignares est-ce qu'on risquerait pas de
perdre nous mêmes ce potentiel là on se
reposera juste sur cette ia et de perdre
cet esprit humain et rentrer dans ce
qu'on pourrait appeler une sorte d'
idiocracy parce qu'on perdrait cette
créativité ce qui fait l'essence humaine
donc la créativité humaine et on
finirait par s'annihiler nous mêmes mais
pas physiquement mais plutôt sur dans le
domaine de l'esprit est ce que ce ne
serait pas une possibilité aussi autant
que l'apocalypse
bref un présupposé par ostrom
juste pour reprendre l'exemple que
j'avais déjà développé parce que du coup
ça répond bien imaginer que tony voilà
un logiciel soit capable d'écrire des
romans mieux qu'à renaître faut dire que
c'est une perte puisque du coup les
experts ont pu le faire plus écrire des
romans c'est plus d'intérêt possible que
ça diminue fortement
on peut aussi se dire que d'un autre
côté il y aurait sans doute bien plus de
bons romans qui serait écrit de cette
façon là certainement mais qu'en est-il
de l'humanité parce que ses romans là ne
feront pas partie de l'humanité mais
d'une super intelligent ce qui est
complètement artificielle qu'en est il
du reste de l'humanité
qu'en est-il de développement de cette
humanité la comparer à au développent
développement d'aujourd'hui on n'a pas
le choix si on veut qu'ils aient des
bons romans on est obligé d'avoir des
écrivains qui les écrivent qu'ils
passent leur vie à ça ça au moins que là
au contraire la possibilité pour dzfoot
des personnes pour qui c'est important
d'écrire des romans d'écrire des romans
et pour des personnes pour qui c'est
important d'en lire dans lire sauf si on
part du principe que forcément si c'est
écrit par une machine ça a moins de
valeur forcément mais si vous enlevez
cette cette hypothèse là il n'y a pas de
raison surtout si on oublie juste sur ce
cap très précis et pas de raison
de supposer que l'existence d'un tel
logiciel serait pas une catastrophe pour
la littérature
en fait si vous y réfléchissez bien
genre si la macworld avait un serait pas
une catastrophe pour la littérature ce
sera en fait assez formidable que ben la
même façon ce sera un peu similaire à
fait d'avoir un programme qui joue
extraordinairement bien aux gosses et
pas une catastrophe pour le go en
réalité c'est plutôt d'aller en fait les
joueurs du groupe plutôt j globalement
bien accueilli ça parce que j'ai dit
voyez l'occasion de voir des choses
qu'ils n'avaient jamais vu
en fait il ya aussi ça il ne pourra que
vous pourrez envisager l'idée qu'il
créativité qui est propre justement à
cet ordre là deux choses faire face à
des joueurs de 2 go de très haut niveau
artificiel français plutôt que par
exemple qui excite intellectuellement
les gens de gauche plutôt que l'inversé
this page
c'est bon le jeu de go est mort je vois
pourquoi en fait dans d'autres
disciplines
intellectuel dernier a pas de même
quelque part je serais très curieux de
lire un le meilleur roman qu'une qu'une
ia serait capable d'écrire aujourd'hui
il écrit des scénarios mais c'est pas
très bon mais mais ça serait
intellectuellement intéressant aussi
quelque part oui
tout d'abord merci thibault d'être venu
ici à lausanne pour cette conférence
très intéressante
vous développez enfin dans la seconde
partie de cette conférence vous vous
développer tout un raisonnement pour
nous expliquer que une super
intelligence artificielle de type ia
pour être potentiellement une menace
pour lui mérité mais dans la première
partie de cette même conférence vous
expliquer qu'une intelligence collective
une intelligence sociale pourrait être
une forme de super intelligent ce
bizarre donc j'en reviens à ma question
on peut quand même se poser la question
s'il super intelligence de ce type
pourrait pas être une menace mais aussi
pour limiter ça me fait penser que j'ai
pu dire un truc cette chose là qui est
que la supervision sociale elle est
particulièrement difficile parce que
notamment on a ça on n'a que chaque
objectif intermédiaire dont voilà dans
la réalisation d'un objectif par cette
super intelligence sociale est réalisé
par un être humain particulier il ya
beaucoup moins ce risque des objets de
mal à ce problème les objectifs
instrumentaux il est beaucoup moins il
peut quand même
il peut même se poser je pense
effectivement ça peut être une crainte
légitime aussi mais il est très limité
par ceux ci par le fait que finalement
c'est une somme d'actions humaine donc
les êtres humains seraient pas n'importe
quoi
ordonné il ya pas un par erreur parce
que voilà c'est ça mène à ça permet de
danser les gens sur la lune
quelqu'un qui radient créé toutes les
stations et lisa mais moi j'avais eu
comme but voilà ça n'a pas de sens
justement parce qu'on a ça bosse ici
une des différences avec super
intelligence artificielle qui est que
c'est une somme d'actions humaine qui
produit une coordination assez folle qui
produisait super intelligent c'est le
fait que ce soit des actions humaines sa
limite tout n'est pas valorisé ce qui
est une dernière question
alors moi je veux parler de de ce
qu'elle a parlé de la nidation de
l'intellect humain vs le roman l'exemple
du roman si au final j'ai l'impression
que c'est un choix et je me demande qui
doit prendre ses choix
comment être sûr de ce choix qu'on veut
continuer dans la main telligent ans
artificielle et si on prend un choix de
oui ou non
doit-on vraiment abandonné enfin c'est
vraiment la question du choix c'est à
quel moment
ba qui doit le faire et le romain et
l'annulation l'intellect
au final c'est vraiment on doit choisir
ou pas de continuer dans l'intérêt dans
l'intelligence artificielle et qui
choisissent comité des gens qui décident
non bien sûr justement est justement
widnes et c'est un problème c'est qu'on
n'a pas le sentiment que quelque chose
comme un comité de décider bon
finalement on arrête
brett favre a pas de sens on sait ça
paraîtrait assez fou qu'on décide de ce
sont des recherches d'améliorer tout
forme un des genres textuels de peur de
quelque chose dans ce goût là ça paraît
très fou donc de cette façon le choix
en tout cas le choix de poursuivre ou
non dans la danse et recherche laclare
le monde n'appartient à personne
personne peut le prendre et personne ne
l'a pris non plus je pense que je pense
conclure je suis sans permis de réagir
j'ai juste envie d un coupe gorge parce
que je pense qu'on va produire à nouveau
thibault ils ont remercié
[Applaudissements]
merci à vous d'être retenues contre ceux
qui sont pour ceux qui sont sur youtube
a rejoint d'ici juillet nous sur actions
pendant une demi-heure où toute fin tout
à l'heure merci
bon
oui
ça tombe toujours la demande est forte
encore
à
et vous
ah ok avec un montage
[Musique]
l'entreprise
jusqu'à moment ça
pensez à ça
parce que c'était un rapport au basilic
de rocco oui oui